good morning John this video comes in
three parts part one me singing a song
it's one that's called four-foot
squirrel but it is not by me it is by
Tom Milson also named hexa chordal on
YouTube I was chatting with him online
and I told him that I was working on a
song about a homicidal squirrel and he
said hey I have a song about a squirrel
and he sent it to me and then I covered
it and here it is
woof woof it's worldwide EU stands up
song well I think it's trickery and
you're not big at all your health all
through dreams up high kinda had you
sprout don't get so discouraged that be
nice all right through your steam fur
after all what concerts was want to do
but dream but patiently tractor somehow
crept into your head whilst all the
other squirrels jumped of hazelnuts
instead
why do you look away are you offended by
the harshness that we say just bear in
mind friend that whatever you do will
always be there just to point and laugh
and Tom Milsom click right here in the
box in the box text chordal and this is
probably gonna be the last cover that I
do here at vlogbrothers so if you want
to continue hearing my covers I think
that I will be doing more at youtube.com
slash dftba records click here whoo
there are no giant squirrels in America
but I did go on Wikipedia and find other
there are indeed giant squirrels in the
world the Indian giant squirrel is not
quite 4 feet it is 3 feet from nose to
tail and it's quite beautiful I think
that you should check out the Wikipedia
page and learn all about the Indian
giant squirrel
it's a threatened species that lives
throughout peninsular India but do
allenl of stuff got published a book
about you do interview with me here if
you would Lisa Nova interview with
Michael Buckley and I've been reading it
actually like cover to cover which I
never do with non-fiction books and
there's a foreword by this guy who you
might know author of New York Times
bestseller Paper Towns it actually says
that on there we go well and think it's
them to change that that was quick on
the front here it says no one knows more
about building a youtube fan base than
YouTube star analyst Dufty Allen and his
co-author the well owned independent
filmmaker Michael W Dean will show you a
variety of effective strategies for
becoming more popular proceeding to the
wisdom of this book and I look forward
to seeing you passed me on the YouTube
most subscribed list John Green youtube
star and author if you would like to buy
one of these there's a link in the
sidebar it's got everything you need
from understanding copyright law to
understand the YouTube community to how
to cheat on YouTube and why you
shouldn't really there's a chapter
called that there's even a little bit
about ethical hacking which Evan and I
have been working on together for the
last week or so which leads me to the
thing 3 which is the project for awesome
which you're going to find out more
about to mom it doesn't make a whole
dedicated video to the project for
awesome and yes it is happening this
year and yes it is happening soon so if
you need time to make a video make one
now because we'll be project for awesome
Inge officially on the 17th of December
and you will find out more about that in
tomorrow's video I will talk only about
the project for awesome and how awesome
it is and if you don't know the project
for awesome means and you should go to
nerdfighters calm right now and sign up
for the project for awesome mailing list
which is on that side of nerdfighters
calm thing 3.5 I guess we are giving
away a copy of Alan's YouTube book do
someone who comments in the comments if
you would like one of these probably by
Christians that you're not gonna win it
but do you believe a comet you will get
a signed copy of YouTube an insider's
guide to climbing the charts the only
YouTube book written by anyone who spent
an actual significant amount of time on
YouTube
Alan low stuff got one of my greatest
YouTube friends leave comments below and
you may get a free copy dftba